[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's monday it's motivational monday oh
yeah positive monday
positive monday welcome to the break
room new rockstars
live show that brings you the nerdy news
directly from our actual break room here
at new rockstar's headquarters i'm uh
thrilled to be zach huddleston and
joined by equally thrilling brain and
bear oh hello jessica clements hey it's
really bright on that tv yeah we're
really bright if we're right at home do
not adjust your computer
on the darker half of the table here
tommy beck told good day oh
we got we got shiho we actually have a a
good amount of interesting she-hulk news
a little rogue one news you and mcgregor
out there talking smack stick around for
all of that
talking smackdown he's talking a lot of
shoes
and shout out to everybody uh throwing
out the trash bags in the chat we
appreciate you we appreciate everybody
in the chat oh look at their graveyard
uh depraved gourds garbage pail kid name
sticking with it graveyard i like it
bless your graveyard uh throwing in a
super chat we appreciate everybody that
throws us a couple doubloons in the
super chat uh we're gonna do a
redemption a day every 50 we hit in a
super chat and on our motivational
monday we're gonna do a motivational
speech 60 seconds one minute 60 seconds
on the clock
and i'm not gonna rhyme it with anything
else that came to my mind initially 60
seconds on the clock to do your best
motivation your best
uh jubilation
your best
uh emancipation yeah a bad feeling free
with no aggravation that's right and
some of these are they're going to be
inspired by
famous film motivational speeches but
really aimed at you the audience because
we're motivated we want to share that
with you our break roomies our roomies
our breakers
complete barrels of trash although as i
always try and say monday is trash day
so there's a chance the trash has all
been taken out that's right
maybe they're fresh fresh bags
uh f in the chat for the fresh bags okay
um but first we want to get to some
headlines
yes very nice uh in an interview with
variety the duffer brothers makers
creators of stranger things uh have
pledged that they're going to focus more
on the original cast in the upcoming
season five i guess this is in response
to like wow they've added so many
characters that last 10 minutes of the
final episode and they have to kind of
show all the characters and where
they're at as the season ends you're
like better focus on how they're going
to kill one yeah that's what i'm talking
about
kill them kids
they keep introducing people and then
using them well they are killing the
kids kids are being killed
okay
on the show well none i mean i mean i
guess eddie was technically an adult i
want to see some of the some of the og
kids yes we got to get to the bottom
yeah even even max who was not he's
don't you throw yourself in a dumpster
and light it on fire give the world up
it's motivation motivation
um i can't uh well and then they went on
to say we're doing our best to resist
for season five adding more characters
right we're trying not to do that so we
can focus on the og character i hope
that freaking mike's weird serial killer
father gets like uh just the whole
episode right he's like wandering around
buying groceries like a bunch of
stranger things keep happening in this
town
mike i wish you know what would be
really strange if you did the damn
dishes yeah maybe if you mowed the lawn
when i asked i don't know why he's like
a weird hank hill character to me also
it doesn't seem like every season his
mom and his dad get farther apart and
age yes
that guy's aging like a freaking rotten
eggplant on a shelf and that mom is
aging like the finest one
oh yeah i mean
i love you stop him mike's dad like
storm the capital right oh
todd in the boys like he is so
problematic yeah he's problematic um
maybe he gets his in the final season
we'll find out kill the kids
all tertiary characters die we're left
with an earth only populated by the
original uh children of stranger things
if you're hoping to brush up on your
rogue one knowledge ahead of andor
getting released hey you could do that
in the theater
no need to stream it or pop in a dvd
august 26th rogue one will be
re-released in imax theaters along with
an exclusive look at andorra itself hey
our friends at imax
send us a ticket yeah we love the little
sneak peeks yeah i mean yeah it's worth
it to see that in theaters again because
that had some of the best like vistas in
the star wars movies that sequence of
jedi getting blown up by the death star
spoiler alert nerds uh so good on like
the big screen song guerrero on the big
screen
[Applause]
it's monday it's positive monday by the
way motivation keep it positive we're 37
bucks away
37 bucks away from a motivational speech
you want to hear me blow out my voice
but i
i'm hanging in there i was doing too
many uh renditions of the cha-cha slide
yeah whoa out on the day because i was
at a wedding oh yeah oh yeah sorry yeah
they weren't playing the cha-cha no
sly
he
all right all right all right all right
all right all right all right next red
line
okay um
ewan mcgregor was at boston fan expo
this weekend and he had a couple
interesting things things to say we love
it when actors show up with these cons
and drop some some little nuggets that
get aggregated uh firstly
he said that the series obi-wan uh
originally had a different storyline it
was going to focus more on obi-wan and
luke
it was going to be that and that was
like one of the genius moments where
they were like wait a minute what if we
did leia instead yeah because like
that would make a new hope so much
weirder
i don't know much about you except for
those eight episodes we spent together
like
nine years ago yeah yeah yeah um or yeah
in the future yes um and then the other
little bone mot that he dropped was that
somebody asked i think would you want to
join the mcu and he was like i'm in this
star wars star wars world i'm not
looking for that that is
a reverse
i think he's playing hard to get yeah oh
that's a that's a drenched dramatist
a a
saturated um
uh scene
thank you um
anders johansen and gravoy throwing in
some super chats there we'll circle back
and answer some of those also i'm not
sure i love it when we get folks from
other countries and then the super chat
shows up in a different denomination
and okay is that norwegian maybe uh
something a croner i don't know i
haven't understood you tell me if you
know what it is
from europe our canadian brethren uh
with the canadian dollars we appreciate
you
it's all right religion i guessed it
yeah uh in fact you pointed out that you
and showed up for a comic book he was in
birds of prey yeah
fine with being in the d.c
rhino or with the black mascot yeah
right his wife was in it too yes i would
do anything with my husband i don't have
anything
no okay not like number four
pop the question i said that you were my
husband and i felt so bad people were
super chatting being like i wanted tommy
i didn't know he was already taken i'm
sorry
save your coins
also if you if people really believe
that they'd be like
like the microaggressions would be that
much more closely monitored is
everything okay at home like what's
going on
why is tommy shying away from her every
time she shouts
what happened last night just so much
um in an interview with the hollywood
reporter aaron taylor johnson of the
upcoming craven the current money train
previously uh quicksilver in age of
ultron uh revealed that he turned down a
role in deadpool deadpool 2
uh which was directed by bullet train
director david leach uh
didn't say why no i think he started i
think he said he they had had
conversations for a minute now
i don't know why it's australia he's in
australia he had it on street hang on
we had a bit of talk about it at the end
of the day carl urban didn't fit into my
schedule yeah
[Laughter]
there's been so many of those in the
headlines did you see the giancarlo
esposito uh being like i think they
wanted me for loki
he said that um yeah he kind of
mentioned that like they came to him
with an offer to be in loki and we're
kind of a that's interesting
like what do you think roley was being
offered
yeah put him in a wig he could do it he
could get it
maybe it was between him and richard
grant oh
yeah that makes a lot more insane to me
because i'm like they are two very
different actors but they're both very
stoic but richard grant is bigger to me
or bigger as in like a bigger like holy
crap than seeing jean-claude i see john
crowley's music all the time i barely
see richard graham anymore yeah so i'm
like that's what and i also like because
richard grant has kind of he's english
dark hair like hiddleston right so it's
like he looks like an alternate older
version of tom hiddleston is there a
world where he was he who remains and
could have been the king
maybe they were going a different
direction
maybe maybe at one point they still had
jonathan major's mind but not like not
all the variant kings look the same yeah
which is fine they are then they have
like all of those loki's were all very
very i mean one was an alligator one was
an animal yeah so i think okay were the
same but a lot were very different yeah
yeah old old beautiful black man um
which and it's also we were also joking
because giancarlo lately who's been
tearing it up on the con scene man that
guy's been given some of the best quotes
out there he's always a good time he
just likes to travel because he is at
every convention he has fun he was in
yeah he does have a great time we casted
him in a college humor show uh last
season and he was just like i just do
this for fun and i was like you're a man
of millions of dollars i don't know how
long he's been acting for but like
someone like brian cranston who didn't
find success until much later their
acting career yeah and then they soak it
up and they love it well
has been around forever i mean do the
right thing was uh mid-80s right
but like he
leveled up much later after breaking and
you get that you get that freedom to do
more things that you're having fun with
once you're like at that age
and like you know when you're maybe 50
60s however old he is like you know also
maybe your kids are out of the house you
know what i mean you get to kind of bask
bask in the glow reap the rewards of
this great career that you've lived but
we were also saying because he had that
great quote a few weeks ago where he's
like throwing out potential marvel roles
you could play and he said
uh dr freeze he's afraid she's not a
character so we were like could he be
confused was he approached maybe about
moon knight or hawkeye or some other
series because i genuinely just don't
know the characters are so funny to me i
want to play hat man oh yeah
there's a lot of hats like i do like
that's coming up with me i still love
after like russell got cast as ego and
guardians of the galaxy and someone
asked him immediately like a red carpet
about it he's like how do you feel about
playing ego in the upcoming gardens of
gax and he's like i don't know what the
hell you're talking about
he's like i don't get this mumbo jumbo
uh oscar isaac stunt double uh darren
nope nope nope sorry if i'm
mispronouncing your name there darren uh
he posted a photo we have this photo
uh
throwback to when he was in egypt
okay tommy oscar this is me and you
putting our costumes on
a couple of bishops
a couple of bishops on the chessboard
huh
that's a that's a real rorschach for you
everything is valid to you hey speaking
of laughing speaking of canadian dollars
match 143 thank you uh friends from the
north oh 69
currently okay that means we have
unlocked a motivation we'll find out
soon who's going to give that
motivational speech thank you to
everybody um but he kind of yeah that
post was all about like hey we should
make a season two which is again a
thirsty thespian kind of a move
but there's been a lot about
specifically moon knight lately oscar
isaac the director i think they're just
a great team of people that really like
working together and they're going to
make it very obvious that they really
want another season and i am i'm okay
with that and i applaud that because
it's really hard to find like a team of
uh everyone you really enjoy creating
something so culturally great and then
being like we want to move it forward
with the second season
i agree one minute on the clock camera
four please
listen to me
a lot of people in the chat a lot of
people that watch our show
might think that me calling you trash or
garbage person is an insult maybe me
saying that you're not worth
the banana peels and orange peels and
old open campbell soup cans that
surround your habitats
let me tell you about a man
a man who made a difference in a lot of
people's lives his name was oscar the
grouch
and he lived on sesame street and he had
a best friend named slimy who was a worm
and he's currently alive so this past
raising of him is 20 seconds
oscar the grouch got up every single day
even though he was in a pissed off mood
and he still went out there and he
showed up for his friends and he gave
the tough advice when he needed so maybe
somebody you need a hug or maybe some of
you need a kick in the ass today well
i'm here to do both i'm here to hug you
and i'm here to kick your ass
what a motivational motivation
nice work tommy thank you tommy on time
and under budget my man i will say in in
that moon knight news uh and there has
been a lot of buzz about it kevin
feige's about to be the the drama
teacher who pins
who pins the glasses on the wall at d23
yeah
freaking uh dance moms and they're gonna
build up here and
it does make me think that somehow it
has been communicated to this crew that
like your show's on the edge yeah right
like it's not guaranteed it's not easy
money like loki where it seemed like
they were renewed from the second that
show came out and it's also not like
maybe something like hawkeye where
there's never going to be a second
season to that they'll do a k bishop
season or an echo season or something
like that so it's like it must have
filtered down that's like could go
either way you guys should probably
hustle on social media right it also is
like they i love them for this they knew
they were like hey you get one season
we're gonna even post this on like for
the enemies as a
limited series and they're like okay
well we're just gonna leave the ending
so open-ended
oh that wasn't me oh yeah my phone's not
on silent because i need the timer to be
in the ring sorry guys uh let me just
see if that was hollywood calling who
are you texting uh
my uncle jimmy hi uncle jimmy shout out
to you who sent me a sir aloha it says
and something very religious
love you uncle jimmy love you uncle
jimmy um
our next headline uh
oh a new 30 second spot for
she-hulk which we do have
but
oh we have the image john
okay great which we'll throw the image
up it reveals uh a classic mutant from
the comics el aguila
who is this character who's kind of a
zorro like
uh character who's also traditionally in
the comics is a mutant
he's kind of a swashbuckler
uh and i think i'm saying his name right
aguila aquila something like that but
he's getting thrown on the hood of a car
right by um man bull um it looks like
we're getting a lot of really fun d and
e level uh marvel characters maybe
showing up on the periphery of the show
it's very much like suicide squad or
peacemaker where you can just kind of
throw in the some of the random ones and
you know if this was a mutant in the
comics i don't know if they'll call it
out as a mutant on
she-hulk or if this is if we'll get our
second mutant in seahawk i would assume
we would yeah but we'll have to guess
wait and see i don't know
uh marc lopez mac lopez says lrg
oh like it's a hard g on that okay thank
you thank you mac lopez uh el agila um
cool i i've read a lot of mine
yeah okay i i will still find a way to
mess it up uh despite your
love
um but i love it and i love it like
because you have to imagine they don't
want to burn
good well-known characters they haven't
used yet right it's like they're they're
digging deep enough oh yeah okay right
i've read a lot of comics i've never
heard of el ajila uh at all um which is
wonderful thank you diego rodriguez you
might be pushing us up we're getting
dangerously close to a second
motivational
one travis just just did it thank you
uh 200
if i've cut my beard i can't that's what
hides my giant face from the public
needs
for hollywood needs him to have a beard
hollywood will pay tens of thousand
dollars to make this boy's shape so you
gotta you gotta try it out cast me on a
tv show and i'll shave that's right
uh willing to shave as he says in his
sleep um i say desperate to shave
everywhere
get manscaped on the phone yeah uh in
another a little she-hulk tidbit um
supposedly this came out shield is going
to introduce a tony stark wannabe
character named todd played by the actor
john bass
um
todd which is a great name um producer
wendy jacobson described the character
as a billionaire playboy philanthropist
douchebag who wants more than anything
to feel like tony stark but comes off as
john bass
the actor the actor oh i messed that up
bass said that oh okay he said that not
that now jacob said she said another
quote about how funny he is so that was
my fault not to misquote anyone john
bass referred to himself uh kind of uh
you know uh
uh self-effacingly he'll be playing a
john bass type on the show um but i like
that like we were speculating
like could todd be a marvel character is
this just like a random rich guy that
she interacts with or dates or something
like that like what's your best guess
i that i mean
he'll probably be like a bad version of
tony stark because i don't think he's
going to be like a powered person he's
just going to be like a rich well when
you say bad version do you mean like
like some of the other evil people i
mean like not altruistic i want to save
my prediction prediction for something
very
i do believe
that he will start off as someone who
goes on a date with her and that date
goes wrong
and that motivates him to maybe behave
in a way that is uh
uncouth and dangerous to uh all people
okay we got 140 gtqs coming up oh
john figure out what what uh currency
that is zest 13 thank you very much gran
turismo quarters
guatemalan molly yes
my man also it looks like jessica is
giving the next motivation okay we're
not far away from another one after we
add all these up i mean one of these
watch the break room and you may die
run and you'll live at least a while and
dying in your beds many years from now
would you be willing to trade all the
days from this day to that for one more
episode of the break room just once oh
wait just one chance to come back to
twitter and tell our enemies that they
may take our lives but they'll never
take our watch time
she's still got 30 seconds so you guys
are really great people and if you're
having a really hard week it's monday it
just started but also you're allowed to
have a bad week and you're allowed to be
as upset as you want to be because you
are living and you are a person and
people have feelings and you're allowed
to express your feelings just make sure
you're not harming yourself or others
and i'm okay with what you do yes and i
say if you want to harm yourself in a
fun safe environment with some tarps and
ropes call me up i have a little
sideways now
what's that side this is called oh it's
called tommy takes over
time you have tommy sign me up time to
update my time for tommy
all right guys 21 more dollars till
someone else can motivate you in ways
you never thought possible and i'll say
this
if we get above 250
i'm going to deliver a really special
motivational speech something i've been
cooking up for a while to get the break
rumors ready and excited as we approach
you know we have our 100th episode
coming up yes
right after that it's spooky season okay
yes it's we're going into halloween and
i'm not we're not doing halloween for a
week on the break room we're doing
halloween for a fortnight like
shakespeare october 1st halloween begins
on the break room uh we're getting
spooky i'm getting decorations in here
i've got my boy uh gorgash who some of
you have known has followed me around
for a long time gorgash has moved into
interior design uh better homes and
gardens described his uh his most recent
design is what
i hate when you do that so uh gorgash
will be in here chopping up the studio
chopping people apart maybe we might
have live body parts i'll swallow a
goldfish i don't know how
so
that's all i got to say about that i'll
probably dress up every day all right i
plan to yes 31 days of cosplay maybe
yeah maybe i dress up every day i wear
the mask of a happy man oh no somebody
needs some monday motivation oh boy uh
yeah we have huge plans this is a good
point to talk about some things we have
coming up thank you to everybody that
watches every day we've got some cool
things cooking we're not too far off
from our 100th episode we're going to do
a big tamicon level event that's for the
100th episode but you know not so
focused on me it's an inclusive we got
the core four that's right it's gonna be
it's every year it's gonna be better
that's gonna be better
you guys let me host the show
i've said this before and i try and stay
consistent is when two men talk to each
other about snacks
uh without mentioning a woman
that's impossible film juice how dare
you how dare you show your face on this
episode of film juice i'm just always in
cahoots with graveyard always mixing it
up with our other chat menaces
film juice is probably he'll get like
the jorge i don't know or she will give
like 300 to get us to just ram our heads
into a brick i know
you won't rest until i'm dead
for every 300 i'll get a doctor to
diagnose me with cte
okay so we hit 600 you'll get two
diamonds like an opinion you might need
it if you have enough ct for 900 i'll
kill that doctor
there's not that much money okay um but
also killed for less other things that
are coming up we've got 100th episode
coming up we've got the entire october
of this show is going to be wild and a
lot of fun and
um
this week we're going to be doing
obviously she-hulk comes out this week
we've got a couple more she-hulk
headlines to go over we
uh the four of us also koi erica wusu
john a couple other familiar faces from
the break room we're all going to be
doing a she-hulk prediction fantasy
draft yeah okay where we're going to be
things like
fun marvel cameos which character might
die like all kinds of predictions we're
going to be drafting those so we can
compete all season long the winner of
that competition is going to get both
their face on the back wall is the
employee of the month okay yep and i'm
calling it the wall of champions the
wall of champions champions because you
know the plan is if the she-hulk league
takes off we're going to do this for
other shows every series
yeah uh and um we're toying with like
what the other part of the prize is but
probably white glove service level uh
fancy meal served live on the break room
talk at a steak dinner brought in by by
a professional server oh can we use this
yes
[Applause]
well i'm sure that the people that pay
for this show are desperately helping
you plan correctly because mine's going
to be seven stakes stacked on top of
each other
with a live lobster holding them
together like a toothpick uh all on a
bed of polar bear testicles yeah um
hearing that meal motivates me but i
really need brandon to read us a
motivational speech here we go he did
another redemption one minute on the
clock brando okay this is i'll give it a
little pacino okay
i gotta get in the zone
now i can't make you do it you gotta
look at the commenter and the chat next
to you look into their eyes
now i think you're gonna see a breaker
who will go that inch with you
you're gonna see a roomie who will
sacrifice themselves for this team
because they know when it comes down to
it you're gonna do the same thing
okay that's a team trash bags yes and
either we heal now as a team but we die
as individuals wow that's the breakroom
that's all it is
oh
wow you should have got another feature
15 seconds if you want to add anything
believe in yourself yes
yes believe me believe in yourself yes
believe it believe it that's a naruto
reference oh there we go good motivation
brandon wonderful
the club mmj 29.97
26 more dollars to complete the set
seo panther thank you for everybody i i
have a little theory here on why zach
has not won yet i do believe that the
chat knows that probably of the four of
us the person here most likely to
someday deliver a motivational speech is
zach
and there they what they understand
right now is they could be moved to
tears by any genuine motiva motivational
speech given by zach so right now i
think there's a little fear from the
church wow i sense a little fear they're
like well if i put 26 more dollars in
the super chat my life might change
forever and that's the type of step that
feels scary on a monday i don't know i
just bought different fabric on my
underwear for the first time i'm not
doing the stiff cotton anymore i'm doing
the soft
tri-blend fabric with an elastic
waistband that makes me go
maybe i don't jump into a river today
maybe i
i wade in and i swim
is this a hypothetical viewers monologue
this is tommy's monologue you know what
i blacked out
all right okay
i'll get reader jessica gao is that how
we're pronouncing her last name yeah am
i saying that right thank you um spoke
with tv line and shed some light on when
the show takes place on the mcu timeline
uh which that's interesting because not
all these series has been confirmed to
be kind of
uh sequential right right with how
they're released to us it's not
necessarily how they're taking place in
the mcu um and she said that uh the
series is set not too far after shaun
chi
uh
it's not like years later it's a
relatively short amount of time and
that's important because in chongqi we
saw
bruce banner we see him at the end of
shanghai after the events of that film
and he's a human and he's got the sling
yes we've seen we also saw an
abomination in that film as well
confirmed emil
uh and we've seen in the trailer footage
we've seen both uh a smart hulk and a
bruce a regular bruce yes yeah uh in the
car with her and when you that clip of
them riding in the car i think he had
the sling on than that so it's like
yeah that makes sense hopefully we'll
get some idea of what's going on with
honestly i just want to know like the
year uh which i think we do know i think
because we were like chun chi is like by
his age 2024 but then it's like on the
mcu timeline on the dar uh darval plus i
don't know why i was gonna say that
disney plus uh it's just there's
eternals there too so i'm like is this
they think i don't always trust the
timeline on disney plus
i think they passed that down to an
intern and it's not getting back to
myself so that you're going to this
because it does seem like it's sean chi
happens and then like spider-man no way
home happens
and then so that that is and then doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
happens and then miss marvel happens
moon knight we don't know where that
really is
they put what they put that in hawkeye
like right before miss marvel
and the
the timeline which is true
spider-man real close to each other
because they're both at christmas time
yes well the same embarrassment well the
the tag at the end is i don't know how
much time happened between the end of
spider-man only home and him swinging
through new york city in the snow yes so
it is like winter time when he sees mj
yeah yeah the donut yeah yeah and then
and then miss marvel was like here's the
thing you're at the donut yeah here's
the day of the year yes
frosting off yeah
all right okay
okay
i do have to do a motivation i also say
we're still we're only 19 bucks after i
motivate we're only 19 bucks away from
the next motivation which i think might
need to be a group motivation i'm just
saying now that everybody's done i think
it's 300 right
okay well all right zach one minute on
the clock here's what i want to say you
know what i could read this one inspired
by rocky
camera 4 yes
listen i'm i'm talking to everybody in
the chat but specifically
anders johansson yes
mr feeney
match143 oh old gregor
and not
film juice yes
my nemesis okay
but all the rest of okay i don't say
jack kent uh graveyard uh battle for
beauty courtney scott i'm talking to you
jordan mad stupid i'm talking to you
avril i'm talking to you kenny g420 okay
okay
i'm talking to you right now all right
i'm reaching
through
your device through your ipad through
your laptop through your phone however
you're watching us right now
and if you want more
we'll have to wait till the next one oh
my gosh that's just
that's the preamble
some motivations need two minutes all
right i don't know if that was a tear
jerker but it's definitely a something
jerker
oh
a jerk around is activating sleeper
agents within the chat oh yeah i just
saw a bunch of people go acknowledged
what are my orders uh so there's one
other uh thing that came up in in that
jessica gao interview
uh or in one of her interviews she's
been giving promoting she-hulk uh she
brought up a topic that's fascinating to
us and it seems like it's gonna be a big
part of the show yeah she was talking to
the direct and she said that uh towards
the back half to this show they're gonna
get into the sokovia accord they're
gonna come back and they're gonna she
said directly well this show will answer
the question of whatever happened to the
sokovia accords you remember those
things she promised you will get an
answer to what actually happened to the
accords okay so what are what are the
sokovia coins you all know you trash
bags you you breakers you rumors you all
know but these dum-dums here i got to
remind them what it is
they first showed up in civil war
they're of course named after the great
state of sokovia dropped from the sky uh
the home place of my boy baron zemo the
best man in the world yeah uh he was
right the only one to beat the avengers
you know him uh that's where they first
showed up in civil war basically the
avengers been running around causing
problems getting people killed okay 74
people died in the battle of new york
that has to be a lie that's a cover-up
yeah uh way more than 74. go re-watch it
oh my god deep marvel state this should
be a show on this yeah we just uncover
all the marvel lives the the courts they
of course caused the civil war the break
between uh the the avengers where you
know tony the one who was right uh all
agreed that everyone should have to sign
up and be regulated cap that traitor he
ran away with all his his he took his
boy you call him a trader yeah he's a
traitor
but what the sokovia accords are okay
the rules and regulations for the
activities of enhanced individuals
both in the government so like agencies
like shield and private sector the
avengers are technically private they're
funded by tony stark uh this was like a
set of laws basically set up by the u.n
it was ratified by 117 countries and
this happens in 2016 mcu i just want to
also point out real quick i believe
somebody can look this up chrissy in the
chat or somebody i think there there are
about 129 countries in the world so
there's about a dozen countries that
refuse to sign this account
point that out
there are countries that i i refuse to
sign like human rights
legislation not signing the accord
north korea refuses that side of the
story we've got any north korean viewers
throw a couple of balloons in the chat
and by the way i keep my promise i will
do the break room live your excellency i
will bring over a crew of nerds me
rodman seagal the whole gang we're
coming over there seagal's gonna get his
hair painted just special for this we we
appreciate you supreme leader born on
the back of a rainbow unicorn
diving deep into the oceans uh with the
strength of a norwal and i'm sure the
penis of a whale shark
thank you kim jong i'm coming to you
baby break room live you don't have the
balls to have this show oh my god
okay so yeah north korea doesn't send us
to kobe awards uh it leads to the canada
the leads of the civil war right so like
cap if you remember cap
black widow vision
uh
which they go on the run uh uh winter
soldier of course yeah motivators yeah
remember at the end of civil war right
they all get arrested they're in the
jail tony breaks him out he feels bad
but then infinity war happens and the
snap happens and we don't really hear
much about the sokovia chords for a long
time after that but jimmy wu actually
brought it up in one division uh when it
came discovered that hayward had taken
vision's body and was using chaos magic
to activate vision's body the magic that
was left over on some remnants from the
hacks uh jimmy wu says that like that
goes against the sokovia courts so they
are still in place after
uh the events of the blip uh and the
snap
now uh talking to winter soldier kind of
showed how like the world fell apart and
things were out of place and now that
everyone's back they're trying to get
things back in place so that makes sense
that the sokovia accords would come back
into play we don't really know
what is in the sokovia accords agent of
shield would bring it up all the time
but we don't know how canon all that is
watch them now that like wanda's gone
they're like oh we don't really yeah
it's basically saying like if you're an
enhanced individual you have to register
like your identity and your biometric
data with the u.n
and real quick like sam wilson who
doesn't have any super soldiers
a normal guy he does have cool uh
machines and shields and stuff like that
now but he would also have to register
yes yeah i think
does he have to register his weapons
wasn't that like the biggest thing
and his weapons are technically
government-owned it's really messy it's
there's a lot of parts to it because
technically vision was owned by the
government
yeah uh even though it belongs to helen
show let him go home to his mom that's
why australia said nor
and and new zealand said nor why
norway
norway said yes so so how is this gonna
how how do we think the sokovia accords
will play into she-hulk it's gonna have
something to do with like blonsky uh
abomination is you know emil blonsky was
a guy who was being misled by
thunderbolt ross yes who got rejected
with the serum and was following orders
wars uh it's a great line of defense to
take i was just following orders all
right uh historically not backed by the
courts no no no nuremberg didn't really
enjoy that this is normanburg baby the
sokovia dog okay it's just following
words
but we were talking about it it is
perfect in that like we know she hopes
going to be a legal show right she's in
courtroom she's gonna be defending some
of these characters uh they're setting
up a superhero legal uh division or
whatever uh the one law we know about
that exists in the mcu that doesn't
exist in real life are the second
accords right so maybe it's a lot of
like
uh
article 14 of the sakuvia of course is
this person guilty of violating the
accords is this person can reinforce the
accords on this person and she-hulk says
no
it's so insane to create something that
big on like just earth when it's like
this is
eventually even in the comics she hulk
has like done universal law yeah where
it's like what are the sokovian courts
to the like watchers they're like what
does it mean to an ass guardian right
yeah all the asgardians now live on
earth and are part of new asgard so they
probably have to follow earth's rules
sure uh but what happens if you don't
sign the yokobia courts if you're an
enhanced individual who is there to stop
you is there's no shield anymore there's
a sword and there's a dog that from
civil war we know they've still probably
not signed right like cap came around
and eventually signed and there was
there was some amnesty given you know in
falcon winter soldier they kind of
talked about how the winter soldier was
given amnesty everything that happened
uncle jimmy get out of here grandpa turn
off your phone
i wish i got hit up this much
i haven't had that many ticks in the
last week
what i think about
what i think it might happen is that if
you have people not signing is this
where
nick fury comes back to earth
if he's working with sword and sword is
like the legal arm of dealing with
enhanced individuals along with the dodc
is it going to put us in a position
where you have like nick fury going up
against she-hulk because we assume
she-hulk's not going to be cool with it
yes or will she because she's already i
love and again we we might get like a
lawyer to come on the show at some point
during she-hulk and talk about like the
real life if we can afford their billing
hours
and we cannot um but we know a few
lawyers that have flamed out of the
legal industry
currently pursuing clowning careers so
if you're a disbarred lawyer uh
if you're shamefully disbarred we'd love
to have you on any of the people that
have represented me in the past come
dirt chief i'm talking about my my main
attorney uh dr nasty you know i'm
talking about
the second motivational oh not another
one i'm talking about tyler turn his
phone back on i'm talking about you
benjamin napolitano i'm talking to you
again match143 yeah yeah i'm talking to
you quentin yeah belsky yeah sean canary
palomares
yeah i'm talking to to you all okay
because it's motivational monday all
right you don't need
you don't need some goofball little
league coach looking doofus
on a device to tell you to get motivated
okay
all the motivation you need is inside
you
okay now wait until this show's over
okay watch it till it's duration maybe
even re-watch it so we can accrue that
kind of adsense watch time okay but as
soon as that's completed
i want you to tap into that that inner
well it runs deep it goes to the core of
the earth and that yeah that makes the
water warm okay tap into that warm water
well of motivation you have inside of
you okay start texting tommy yeah
reach down if you have time these
numbers start texting me text him right
now live on the air
oh my god
turn it okay use anyone else's phone now
sorry guys
i'm just jealous that was just the timer
okay hey you want to hear the rest of it
30 bucks away okay
we did ask in the chat do you think will
be for or against the sokovia accords
against that 53 percent which might make
sense i think they paint them as a bad
thing but tony stark was right well and
if they
if if they are active if they're signed
into law she becomes powered after
they're signed into law right they
affect her right she doesn't get a
choice to sign or not sign and in fact
even people that never signed like
you're still impacted by laws you do not
vote for or consent to right
i think the signing was also to give
them a little immunity for past for best
uh instances i think i'm saying jessica
gao also mentioning that this is going
to be the end towards the end of
she-hulk i think this is going to be the
moment where she's like i'm getting out
of here then i'm starting my own firm
and i think that's what will happen
jerry mcguire yeah i think the cycovia
or the sokovia accords are going to be
like too much to handle and overall it's
like you you can't stop it even if you
if you see what's wrong with it and it
makes no sense it's like she's just one
woman and that's when she's like then i
just won't work for this firm like i
will go make my own where i choose my
own cases and i don't get to defend this
piece of crap i can pick we can all
picture that like seen in the last
episode where she's like putting her
name on the door or like putting the box
on the desk scraping off the old door
jones jacobson and
bitch-ass esquires and she's bought the
building and she's like there's only one
[ __ ] ass in this building now there's
so much [ __ ] out there
[ __ ] ass on this show i don't want to
mic oh sorry
why didn't
but i'm wearing my portland shirt but
are you talking to me i will say though
in defense of the sokovia courts there
are good things in there
one of the things is that when you sign
it as a country you're not allowed to
have enhanced individuals in your police
force or in your military so they are
important we do need these countries
because we all love having the
adventures but you know uh if if a
country with nefarious intentions gets a
hold of enhanced individuals and starts
using them in a bad way it's an argument
yeah well it's it's an arms race you get
a red guardian captain america kind of
put on a macro much less cuddly
level i think the sakovic are still too
like yeah like who's on it because if a
freaking val's team's on i want to be
honest you know and that's always the i
mean but that's the thing with laws
right well criminals don't follow laws
so like why do we have laws
this is what we need remember when you
were in elementary school i was there
for 14 years okay not by choice and not
by their choice
but we were it was basically a standoff
it was a stare down
anyway remember how they would like put
like the declaration of independence and
other things in like these cute
infographics that explain them i need
like a schoolhouse rock style sokovia
accord video
well i'm only a score
i'm feeling bored oh look up there it's
an island it's time to make sokovia a
course
we don't sing enough on this show
we need to get the gang that did the uh
was it the applebee's or was it
the chili's the chili's coming we need
to get those those guys in here
bones and blood on the ground
quick silver shot in the chest
oh
but anyways all that is to say again we
could not be more excited for she-hulk
the possibility yeah this show already
in the trailers is showing us again a
sense of humor a fourth wall breaking
legality sexiness right stuff we have
not seen any other stuff big gas big
green gowns these are green gals uh
just a weird threesome video never mind
don't do it ah
wwg that's motivational you're right b
what'd you say whoa okay well right
before it we're going to do an all group
uh motivational speech here but real
quick speaking of she-hulk we want to
promote our good friends at the epic
hero shop who made the shirt i'm wearing
who made their shirt tommy's wearing who
made that wonderful sakovia vodka who
makes the shirts that jessica often
wears not the one she's wearing today i
do normally i don't feel bad about it
she represents the brand frequently but
um they make all this great merch
they've got a really cool line coming
out for she-hulk uh our our new latest
obsession shirt
what is pop when you saw her tom
someone
big green girls you can ride around
not getting caught by the filter in chat
and they love it yes
green green eggplants in the chat um
they have a they have a new line of they
have a whole line of shirts in merch
coming out for she-hulk uh and they have
a uh it's called lady justice is the new
latest obsession shirt now for that one
ladies and gents limited edition
collectible cool shirts when you buy it
you can leave a message that um
eric tommy i know eric mt and jessica
will talk about on inside marvel that's
right because
guess who's breaking down she-hulk oh
yes
[Laughter]
hulk stock
those shirts are already available you
can grab those from epic hero shop.com
also they got cool shirts coming out
soon for uh house of the dragon and door
i think they're working on some stuff
for rings of power so keep an eye out
keep an eye out okay someone in the chat
said you down with bdg yeah yeah
let's go oh man well i feel like today's
episode's been pretty serious so much
let's have a little fun now
mandatory fun hit the graphics
that's right well actually before we get
to motivational fun or mandatory fun we
broke a motivational plateau here oh
cucumbers in the chat
is the cast motivational speech
here's what i'm going to do
i'm going to put two minutes on the
clock
and as a group we're going to gang-bang
this motivational speech okay
we're going to i'm going to be a real
greek salad
we're going to unload some motivation
we are going to unload we're going to
run a train on this motivation
two minutes on the clock all right
hey maybe there's a train you need to
run this week
maybe maybe you've been thinking life
has been too stationary for me i need to
get up on a train and run some trains
over life okay that's right maybe maybe
you've been maybe you've been looking at
things from the same perspective okay
you've just been looking head over heels
right maybe you need to flip that maybe
a partner is head over heels and you're
here
hey hey you know what maybe it's not an
eiffel tower but not for power you know
whoa
you know the caboose might be empty
right now baby but you're gonna fill it
up all right
maybe you got a suckling pig that you
need to spit roast okay
hey listen to me
you may see them as cowboys riding up on
the train to rob them you know what i
see new partners interesting people to
get to know throw some keys in a
fishbowl this weekend
take your wife out on a date wink at a
couple flash a pineapple at them let
them know you're part of the culture
don't be afraid pineapple's in the chat
for the swingers pineapples in the chat
for everybody
hey curiosity didn't kill this cat or
this kid
did someone say yard games because we're
busting out the corn hole this weekend
don't forget to stop by the dining car
because you know it eating cheese baby
and that train starts slowing down okay
if there's a little less coming out of
that smoke stack yeah all right you know
get a little fuel for the fire
i don't really feel the need to do the
actual segment we had planned now this
show's basically over why don't we read
some super chats and maybe get to the
point tomorrow
we got a good other mandatory fund that
will run tomorrow you should definitely
tune in tomorrow but yeah shout out
ethan rivera jessica i love you daddy
both our mommy and our daddy uh
well gregor uh for more motivation thank
you uh we oh we had a couple more polls
brandon could you read out there uh yeah
when we were talking about stranger
things we asked who's death hurt the
most 68 percent of you said eddie which
is barb erasure i won't have it that's
right uh how dare you forgive barb bro
shawn aston pretty tough too yeah it's
not fair to put eddie munson even in
that category
more rats jumping off the barb ship than
nicki minaj fans okay i'm down with the
culture i get what's going on barbs
super freaky girls also
well you go see rogue one at theaters
before watching endor 72 said no that's
fine this better not be an indictment on
rogue one because you gotta pay for it
yeah i know we're out here i will say
right now not a lot in the theaters i
mean i kind of i wish it was out this
weekend i might have i think there's a
couple horror movies coming out at the
end of this movie what are you gonna go
bawl your eyes out at super pets for the
fifth time stop being such a freaking
loser all right you'll see rogue one
that pieces of trash this show has to
end or tommy will be completely mute by
the uh it will lose his voice um but
yeah a couple other um
match 143 garbage person here looking
for a funny interesting story from
eric's wedding weekend
as seen on social media i couldn't make
it unfortunately i wasn't there wait
where are you
going
barb's in the chat see i told you you
called the barbs they show up yeah i
mean we'll leave most of the stories for
eric's to tell but a fun time was had by
the folks a couple folks that from the
channel made it in lovely chicago who
did us a solid by giving us very nice
weather this weekend thank you troy
and you know
zach and i found out as we room together
put the pieces together in your own
brains
yeah we both like to sleep without the
tv on so that's right you know that
that's that's when you know you're are
you one of those people that can't fight
any you guys can't fall asleep without
the tv on you're one of those you're a
tv on person yeah i used to be that way
but i broke out of the habit this is
what i take off before the guy go to bed
the tv all my clothes and all my
paintings off the wall don't come to
life while i'm sleeping and kill me i do
the exact time and your inhibitions yeah
i always break
i break the smoke detector because i'm
pretty sure there's a camera in there
that's right
i'm done getting washed by big smoke no
i think we hit another i pay a guy named
big smoke to watch me
we did get another we did reach another
level i say we end this show on a
motivational speech i say we take it out
jack you want to say goodbye formally
first before we do it yeah thank you so
much for watching again we're here every
weekday 3 p.m pacific 6 p.m eastern uh
what time uh anders johansen are we in
norway is it like 2 a.m thank you my man
um check out the discord if you're not
on our discord you're 18 years or older
go there you can submit a clip of the
week from the show every week it's very
easy on youtube to make a little clip
submit it we hear that at the end of the
week uh you can also leave voicemails on
our discord we're threatening to release
those voicemails obviously the mail we
want to get a good collection of them
together so send them in it could be
nerd questions it could be personal
questions whatever you want uh someone's
chat said we need a break room after
hours and lucky you we're never going to
do that
this show is pretty much the same before
hours again after the break this
particular break room was very after
hours though you can follow us on uh
tick tock where there's a lot of content
that is not on
the break room tommy jessica other folks
doing some really fun work on tick tock
all right clock set
listen to me
we've had a lot of fun today
it's time to stop laughing and time to
start getting to the gym i'm talking
drop sets 30 pound dumbbell curls 20
pound dumbbell curls 10 pounders and
then when your arms are crying for no
more mercy pick up those five powders
this is like an organic opening
it's gonna be a slow build motivation
hey i like how jessica said it not all
weeks are good weeks that's right okay
someone start off rough maybe you
couldn't fall asleep early on sunday
night because you slept in too much
sunday morning right maybe today the day
started slow you needed that extra cup
of coffee your boss is not being cool
your mom calls and is yelling at you for
something okay forget it okay because
tuesday is the monday of tuesday that's
right okay you know what i mean this is
just tuesday junior baby yeah
you know what go out go out go get your
lips greasy you got kfc you can spend
whatever amount of money you want on
ubereats postmates or door dad today's
the day for you to live yourself and i'm
gonna go get me a chicken fried steak
hey did your partner yell at you because
you brought home another funko pot too
bad they're your funko pops you do what
you want with them so i'll get two more
get three more i don't care how many
funko pops you get they're yours collect
them hoard them choo choo choo choo
last night i woke up
screaming
bleeding from my neck to my head
okay
i didn't know what happened i had just
returned home from a long weekend in
chicago with friends celebrating but you
know what i said we gotta stop the
bleeding and start the breeding baby
[Music]
you